[Music]
happy Halloween plays this week we get
monstrous was Frankenstein by Mary
Shelley with some playboy named Walton
peeps some Hood named Frankenstein in
the North Pole
they begin compensating and Frankie
stars filling his life story as a young
and Victor Frankenstein only got two
things on his mind science which he
calls natural philosophy and his cousin
Elizabeth's banging bootay in college
Victor gets so pro at the science game
that he gets drunk off the power and
decides it's time to try and create new
life the result of Victor's experiment
is a busted-up monster so damn ugly now
big the wigs out and trucks it straight
out of town later the muster rolls up on
Victor while he's chilling and gives him
the lowdown on what he's been up to see
after escaping from Victor's stuffy ass
crib the monster poses up in some
village where he starts secretly
creeping on one of the families the
monster learns all sausage from these
homies like how to read and communicate
but none of that fixes the fact that he
lonely is so he decide he gonna try to
chill with these borrowers but as soon
as they catch a glance at his janky-ass
mob they are tweaked out and get the
hell out of Dodge then the monster save
Victor gotta build him a nappy woman
monster then he gonna take to the wilds
of South America where they won't bother
nobody
at first my boy Victor thinks it's a
silent I did but then he starts thinking
hold up what if they started getting
freaky and make little monster babies ah
hell no since Victor went back on his
word the monster gets all torn up and
straight chunks of [ __ ]
Victor's bride Elizabeth so big to the
side he gonna spend the rest of his days
searching the earth to stomp that scrub
but it's a search Victor don't get to
finish cuz he dies chasing his creation
when the monster finds him laying in
Chuck he realizes that he's lonelier
than ever and all that's left of him is
say dog listen up and let me school you
on this book sometime the modern
prometheus with serving up some real
talk on the similarities between victim
and the Titan Prometheus and Greek myth
my homie pro me straight molded human
beings out of some clay and his certain
stories Prometheus was Jones and a give
man a little taste of that heavenly fire
when he boosted it from the gods Zeus
started tripping hardcore just like that
g-dub Titan Victor Jack's fire from the
sky that not only bringing a plague down
on himself
but everybody in the hood but why is
everybody having to ride this beat cuz
Victor was chasing knowledge at the cost
of everything else just like Adam when
he claiming his Fivefinger discount from
the tree of knowledge and the biblical
allusions don't stop there son as the
Original Gangster of the human race
Adam wakes up in Eden is given a banging
honey by his creator and it's ultimately
kicked out of paradise but
Frankenstein's monster as the first of
his kind wakes up in some broke-ass crib
with body parts swung around watches his
woman get ripped apart by his creator
and ain't never gonna find no paradise
sucks to be this fool and it's exactly
all this bunk ass job that leaves the
monster to act like Newton Satan from
Paradise Lost one of the only books the
monsters ever read check it I have cast
off all feeling subdued all anguish to
riot in the excess of my despair evil
henceforth became my good so farewell
hope and with hope their welfare
farewell remorse are good to me is loss
evil be thou my good but the mosque
ain't the only one swinging I'm dark
deeds nah son Victor sippin the same
kool-aid not only do they both waste
each other's Biddy but they handing out
the same street justice vengeance and
when it's all said and done Frankenstein
and his monster ain't so different all
them blurry ethical lines points the
main thematic question up in here are we
inherently good or evil are people
driven to murder because of society or
is it written from day one that a player
gonna be a cold-hearted killer and if so
who's to blame the mosque
or the creator you know thanks for
keepin it og with your boy Sparky sweets
subscribing tune in next week happy
halloween [ __ ]
[Music]